Hey everyone, we are in chapter nine here.
Now, I did avoid a lot of the graphs coming out of the chapter material, but we are going to focus on the concepts that, that are around that chapter material.
I might have to draw a graph or two to explain things, but let's go ahead and dive into our questions.
First question says a firm in a competitive market earns consistent profits above its competitors.
What will likely happen in the long run?
Remember, there are no barriers to entry in a competitive market.
And so anytime a firm is, is earning consistent profits, they're earning economic profits.
Because whatever market conditions are in hold or in place that allow this firm to earn economic profits is going to entice competitors come into that market.
Now, competitors coming in that market, they're going to increase supply, which drives price down.
As price is driven down, what we see is that it gets closer and eventually gets to the point where it equals the marginal cost for the firm.
So new firms are going to enter into the market and driving profits down to zero.
This deals with firms, competitive firms, in the long run.
Where we have changing market conditions, maybe demand or supply both change.
And what we see is that competitive firms cannot earn economic profits in the long run.
All they can do is earn a positive accounting profit or a normal rate of return.
A company's profit spiked $2 million, then gradually returns to their historical average over several quarters.
This pattern reflects what if you're going to your historical average, then you're doing what we call mean reversion.
You're getting back to what you typically do in the competitive markets.
This is what we look at.
We talk about getting zero economic profits.
You get back to what you should be doing because market conditions should be correcting to the point that you can't have those positive economic profits due to the no barriers to entry due to the new entrants coming in to take out some of the profit that you are earning.
Oh, so I guess our answer was B there.
Let's go ahead and scratch that in.  There we go.
And our next question.
Which of the following best illustrates a compensating risk differential?
Now, remember, we talk about compensating risk differential.
I mean, the key word is risk, right?
Here we are in this particular line of work and we're being more being highly compensated for because of the inherent risk and involved in that particular line of work.
So that's something that we're looking for here.
A doctor earns more because of high education costs.  No, you're just.
That's a market thing.
But that's not what we're looking for for compensating risk differential.
Construction worker earns more for working in dangerous conditions.  There you go.  That's your answer.
That should be pretty obvious for us, right?
Because you're in more dangerous conditions.
You have to be compensated for that.
You have to be compensated for the extra risk that you are taking on.
Barista earns more in a downtown cafe.
Maybe if the downtown area is full of violence, but other than that, no.  A tech work.
Tech worker earns bonuses for productivity.
But no, that has nothing to do with compensating risk differential.
The return on risky emerging market bonds falls from 9% to 5% while the risk factor free rate is 4%.
What does that indicate?
Remember the risk premium, we can call it RP here is equal to the risky investment.
The expected return on the risky investment minus what the.
Let's put a little R there for risky investment minus the risk free return.
So rrf, that gives us risk premium.
What investors need to go to that risky investment.
In this case, because it fell, the risky emerging market bond fell from 9% to 5%.
So its return fell by 4 percentage points.
It is exactly in line with the risk free rate of 4% in this case.
What we find is that now the risk premium is way too small to compensate for any of the risk involved with that emerging market bond.
So C is going to be our answer.
We need something much greater than that 4% risk, 4% risk premium to to do it.
Otherwise just go to the risk free bond that's giving us that 4% rate.
A firm earns large profits as the sole provider of a new device or their monopoly.
One year later, similar products flood the market.
What will likely happen?
Okay, so it sounded like they were monopoly to begin with.
But be that apparently there weren't strong enough barriers to entry because we did have new entrance coming into the market flooding that particular market there.
So let's look at these answers.
The firm's profits will grow.
No, that's not even close to being right.
Firms profits will fall.  That sounds more.  That sounds closer.
Being right will fall as prices drop and competitors take market share.  Yeah.
Again what you're looking at is we're just going to assume there's no change in demand.
So the supply demand as.
Let's just draw in the price and quantity.  That's terrible.
But it'll work for right now.
And as the new entrants come in, they flood the market.
That's going to drive down the price and that's going to increase the quantity that erodes market share for the existing firm.
So what we end up seeing is price is going to definitely fall.
And if this is a competitive market or one that's close to a competitive market, it will get us back closer to our marginal cost, which means our profits are also going to fall for that firm.
A firm earns $10 per unit in profit and sells 5,000 units per month.
If five new firms enter the market and total supply increases by 50%, what's the likely effect?
This is exactly the same concept type question that we looked at in the previous question.
There's actually no calculations that I need to make, even though they give us numbers and all this good stuff.
What we're going to see here is C is going to be our answer.
And I should have actually did a better job of getting a different question, but I guess I missed it.
But in this case, again, competition is going to drive down price, it's going to drive down profit.
Firms and competitive markets cannot continue to have economic profit over the long run.
They are going to revert to their mean, which is typically zero economic profits.
Which of the following best enables a monopoly to sustain above normal profits over time?
This is what we call, let's write this out.
Barriers to entry.
If you can keep entrants out of your market, you are able to charge a price greater than what marginal cost would be, which means you can have continued economic profit over time.
That's the above normal profits there.
So you need some type of barrier to entry to do that.
I clearly see the word barrier or words barriers to entry on D there and that's creating legal or technological barriers.  Yes.
In this particular case you have some type of ownership of a key resource.
You have a government granted monopoly, you have some technological barrier that makes it too difficult to get into the market.
Something that's very like, maybe there's an algorithm that you develop that's too complex to be replicated, or you have economies of scale and a natural monopoly.
So that's why we look at D as our answer.
Here we've created some type of legal technological barrier to entry.
It makes it much more difficult for those competitors to to get into this market and compete against you.
Our last question, monopolist faces a downward sloping demand curve and has a constant marginal cost of production.  How nice.
That's nice when that happens.
So here we have our quantity, our price.
This is what the monopolist looks like.
Constant marginal cost of production.
Remember, the marginal revenue curve slopes down faster two times exactly than the demand curve to maximize profit.
What should this monopolist do?
It's quite simple.
You set it to where your marginal revenue equals your marginal cost.
I'm not sure if that's quite the answer that we have available to us, but we're going to find out.
So this is our quantity.
I'm still busy drawing down here.
And this is going to be our profit maximizing price.
This area here represents the total profit that the monopoly is going to get.
Now let's see if I have an answer there.
I think I did see it produce the quantity where marginal revenue equals marginal cost.
That is that point right there.
And that is going to be our answer.
Any other price is either going to give you less profit or it could potentially.
It could potentially, if you chose price way too low, it could give you an economic loss which you don't want to do.
So D is going to be your answer.
That is where the monopolist wants to produce in price.
They're good.  All right, that is it for Chapter nine.
Hope you've enjoyed it.